so you're getting very emotional this is
serious yes of course Heidi really
privileged mail I stopped why do you
have to break the seal on to kill a male
rapist when that male could just not
rape in the first place
I know wouldn't that be great yeah
wouldn't it be [ __ ] great yeah I know
why wouldn't it be great a Mendon rape
yeah it's the latest installment of
changed my mind this time male
priviledge is a myth this is going to be
fun hey really quickly want to hear from
you which subjects would you like to see
most going forward with change my mind
we've done pro-gun pro-life male
priviledge of the myth there are two
genders comment below and we'll be doing
them in the future we'll get to the
unedited segment interview in a second
but one thing that I want to note is
that what these change my mind segments
we can go hours without a single person
sitting down willing to have a
conversation that's the part you don't
see we'll sit down set up and sometimes
it's 30 minutes 45 sometimes it's
several hours and as soon as one person
sits angry left to surround and feel
safe yelling from the mob all of a
sudden I can't get to everyone fast
enough
got it great so if you had true the
statistics of according the FBI
wait so one just food right we noted a
new you know today poo and we would like
to extend invitation should you like to
you can sit down you can sit down
afterwards will do it every fit yeah you
going to turn what was that
there you go that's always a sign of an
intellectual Titan but you'll get a
chance at bat sure now we'll come back
to this gentleman in a minute he's
actually the subject of today's
long-form unedited interview I won't
bore you with many conversations because
it wasn't all that much productive to
glean from it if you look even at her
SMU interviews the one aggressive
feminists kind of took over
it was confrontational but all of the
others were really productive every
other changed my mind we've ever done
has been pretty productive but I noticed
when discussing the idea of male
privilege or any privilege for that
matter on campus not only was pretty
much everyone hostile off the bat but
not a single person provided any
substantive argument every single point
without fail was anecdote what rights
are afforded in 2018 to men exclusively
that aren't afforded to women this is
serious yes of course
Highbury right privileged male of course
I chose it of course but I mean the
reason why I chose it then like shapes
other opinions okay my framing a race
within the first two weeks of coming to
the school as a freshman this also might
be why despite having a permit the
gender studies professors who along with
their students teach the injustice of
police brutality inherently within the
system called the police on us simply
for disagreeing quick bring in the
patriarchy so we weren't really able to
finish our conversations in the first
place and at this point when everything
was anecdotal I kind of just have to
pick one enter this guy the person you
saw before who was yelling and cussing
at me beforehand who also stayed to yell
and cuss at students afterward
you're not a white girl you're not a
girl okay raise your head if you don't
so he's been raped on this campus yes
watch and make your own decisions no
come up and debunk my book so is a great
way to start a civil conversation what's
your name sir Gregory Gregory yes yeah
okay so why the anger and profanity it
was such that those such as that was
such a simple conversation answer your
question so Hank your profanity because
this is an extremely sensitive sensitive
topic with with white with male
privilege and I know you guys the last
conversation was I had a lot about
racial things and you wanted to talk
about lost Ronco are really about the
practicality so practically you know I I
don't I don't have a car here so
sometimes like I like to go down I go to
yoga when I walk back it's at night I
have my headphones on I have like a
hoodie on so I don't know I'm not aware
of my surroundings and I feel perfectly
comfortable doing that I didn't always
are only conscientious of that my entire
life until I got a year ago I was on the
phone with my friend and she said she
need to get her text book from her car
and it was like probably like thirty at
night
and she just wouldn't do it she didn't
feel comfortable she didn't feel safe
sure and so that's something that's
inherent as a male biologically larger
and just like women that's that's an
inherence privilege and hearing
privilege as I mail it well I keep I
illogical ProLogic lee you're going to
be larger taller and you can overpower a
woman and for the most part so you
believe so you're saying that
male/female is biological first off
that's a premise increaseth biological
and and societal and there's also
systemic systemic is gonna be where it's
just ingrained in a society okay so
could you use for example explain to me
what the difference would be between a
biological male versus a systemic male
choose your words I
I say this is they're inserting a
biological male systemic well I'm
talking about systemic male priviledge
and okay we said you say biologically
mine are bigger and stronger right yes
exactly
okay so you're I just want to make sure
we agree on the premise that your snare
logically males have privileged because
they are larger because of that they
have a certain as safety afforded to
them where they can go out and then they
don't have to worry about you talked
yeah it's a horrible horrible comparison
earlier about how males are more
vulnerable to being like to being
burglarized or whatever your thing was
no no I didn't that wasn't what I said
okay what did you say they're more
likely to be like experienced violence
yeah cancer you know all kinda Jen do
that can it can I answer go ahead yeah
no they're statistically more likely to
be victims of violent crime across the
board by which gender know what you just
said you mean gender biologically or
systemically what you just said there
were difference between biological
societal and systemic I want to make
sure we're talking about that yeah
because you're providing the privilege
I'm forgetting the systemic privilege
let's assume I illogical gender it's the
stomach okay well okay
difference okay you okay horse a
biological gender privilege
don't forget the privileges we're very
important yeah it's very important
remember the privilege yeah okay violent
crime many of them would be committed by
men at large domestic violence is very
comparable domestic violence would be
committed on the same rate from with
biological women to men as men to women
sumption than men who are who are more
like vulnerable to violence is what
other men statistically having more at
but being the victim of violent crime
yes statistically also being the victim
of domestic abuse those victims those
men male victims are mostly being
victimized by other men
sure let's go with that yeah sure you
think that's unlikely no I didn't say
it's unlikely let's go with that
okay well yeah I think I think we can
all agree on on that and then so so for
women they don't have that biologically
we're still in the biological part right
when they are law when they're smaller
when they can be overpowered more easily
they they can they don't have the same
privilege when they can't go running by
themselves you've never liked talking
about one sense demons cussing at me so
I'm going to
my sentence and if you want to listen
that'd be great if you don't you don't
have to what I'm talking about here is
privilege I do not see it as a privilege
having a violent crime committed against
you at a multiple rate likelihood other
male whether it by a male but the man
who is getting violently assaulted I do
not believe is more privileged than the
woman who isn't and statistically that's
the likelihood not a privilege because
biologically that male who's being
assaulted by another male has a better
chance of defending themselves than a
female who is being assaulted by a male
and that's the gender difference we're
gonna talk about male privilege sure to
talk about the influence on the opposite
gender don't I don't Nick don't give a
[ __ ] about you when you're talking about
like male on male crime really I do
this is not what this is about talk
about that sure talk about crime let's
talk about crime we're talking about
male privilege yes now I'm bringing up
the biological inherent differences
between the genders I agree on the I
agree that you buy out in German sex and
gender you are less likely and less
capable of defending themselves against
the opposite gender
sure biological I know listen I agree
that's why I'm a huge supporter of women
concealing and carrying no it's not
something oh yeah I think it's different
subject because they're being why I
don't want women what is your trennis
that the premise as though for some
reason women are less likely to seconds
this is not about male Emile's crime and
this is not about access to firearms
right now I want to talk about the
practical different the practical
livelihood our existence why we want to
talk about systemic privilege my
systemic religion he said two seconds
that was about 18 okay I'm going to
speak now and I'm not going to cuss at
you so the point is we are talking about
systemic privilege no one at any point
I'm still open to anyone can sit down
has given me any example of a right
afforded to a man not afforded to a
woman that's what we're really talking
about systemic privilege now we've just
acknowledged both of us that men are
statistically much more likely to be the
victim of a violent crime
we're statistically much more likely to
die at the workplace okay now this is
something that matters to me and perhaps
not to you and then that's okay we can
disagree I don't believe that the man
who is 70 80 percent more likely to have
a violent crime committed against him is
privileged
whether it's committed by another
or not now I would agree maybe we could
find common ground on here what I'm
talking about is I don't want to see
women victimized as a matter of fact
most men don't and the only way a woman
would be able to defend herself against
a violent crime though statistically far
less likely than that of it occurring
with a man would be a mechanical
advantage in a firearm would you not
agree yeah sure no it is no it's about
protecting women it's about keeping
women from being victimized okay cool
that's that's us that's it men have also
but you want to talk about male
privilege so we're talking about
differences between the genders you want
to talk about far I'm so quick let's and
that conversation with this man that's a
major do I have a different
accessibility to firearms no they don't
exactly exactly that's a great their
privileges there you go there's there's
no privilege there's a firearm what I'm
talking about is wanting to a few or if
you let me let me boil it down in a way
that maybe you might be reductive I
would like to read far more headlines
okay that's a rapist shot dead in a
ditch by a woman with a 38 special then
woman raped on campus because of some
concealed carry law okay so I don't I
would exactly you know why how do you
stop why do you have to break the seal
on to kill a male rapist when that male
could just not rape in the first place
I know wouldn't that be great yeah
wouldn't it be [ __ ] great yeah I know
why wouldn't it be great a Mendon rape
yeah who are you arguing with your Don
Quixote fighting windmills man you think
I'm your same way with it they don't get
away with it oh they get away with it on
the smooth campus really yes they do
okay Miami Vice brainy name great within
the first two weeks of coming to the
school as a freshman she was a virgin
two minutes ago Hall you know what that
mother had to do you have to move out of
that hall forget to move out that's
about it really
yeah so this is so this was a rape I
told you things are they written so
you're getting very emotional this is
serious
yes of course hi Mary white privilige
male I can go now okay stay on my phone
my little bubble of TCU I don't have to
turn my back I don't have to worry about
my job my my inktober anything I die
don't the worry about getting grapes
well you should my friends you good
worried you should worry about your own
comes you should worry about
communicating something you should worry
about tree you should worry about
communicating with adults you should
worry about treating on people
respectfully because this will affect
your future employment opportunities you
first came in here and talked about how
you put on your hood of your headphones
you don't even look around in the
periphery that's dumb
that's stupid you should worry about
your safety that's not that's
fundamentally unintelligent white black
yellow red I don't care it's not smart
to do it's also not smart to come in and
say we should get them to stop raping
I'm not your father right I'm not your
father
will you come in here they're gonna
school somebody and cuss and yell and
say you need a sound rapist everyone
here wants to stop rapist everyone here
wants to stop rapists okay the point is
this kind of doublespeak and this kind
of rhetoric and this these kinds of
false platitudes don't help women do you
know what you're doing you're
victimizing actual victims of rape there
is no 1 in 5 rape statistic when you say
men get away with it we allow men to get
off scot-free with rape it's not true
and you absolve people that personal
responsibility the O's no worse Society
leads to a polarize campus it leads to
god forbid actual rape cultures like we
see across the Islamic culture and this
campus is there yeah ok and then what is
the rape culture this is the rape
culture on TCU is is brewed up by first
of all twice of having twice as many
woman has twice and one it creates a
different social dynamic Greek life so
let me continue it let me continue our
first example my friend who was raped
within their first two weeks stare
apology R Lewis
having lost her virginity to rape it's
terrible the the the criminal who was
uncharged was to give a name pledge I'm
not I'm not gonna release this would go
out to a lot of people girl this is not
mine I was always nothing it's not my
decision she did not want to release his
name she did she just don't want this to
be a public thing okay don't judge her
for that so don't roll your head no no
no I am judging okay not her I'm making
it I'm judging the decision you're
judging her victims so I'm dreading the
decision that's a bad decision because
you know what that guy could go forward
and rape another woman
so this stupid false victim status I
don't want that guy to go on leave
nobody oh then cuz she inflamed the
school because a guy Reynard she didn't
give the name do you want to put the
name on publicly cuz she know
how do we stop a rapist if we can't
charge him or get a name here how do we
stop a red meat sauce I'm gonna answer
your question okay
is this decision having the stopping the
racist would be to put him in jail
do you have to have the punishments for
rape to be so significant not just
taking away swimming has caught
scholarship in attendance at Stanford
for that for that rapist but at this
school she did not want to put out the
name and make it a public thing because
she did not want to be associated with
doctor directly this is a small school
she puts out his name her name gets out
there she doesn't want that she doesn't
want to be known as a victim let me
finish the school no she did she did she
did want to prevent that that same
person or his affiliates from raping a
gun okay she told the school okay so the
school and police have his name and
there was a crack he was he was charged
he was no no he was moved out of because
she because he lived in the same Hall as
her Milton then he had to move out of
the hall both freshmen see each other
for the rest of so the police were given
her name of a man who forcibly raped a
woman here telling me they just removed
in from the hall this is the story and
it comes to criminal when it comes that
conviction are there other things that
are needed proof yes exceptional things
and and it's a big one
when we not agree on that yeah obviously
proof is important obviously okay and so
when he comes to the the practicalness
of this event it is lovely talk cuz we
talked about the culture so I'm talking
I going back to the example because
those they were Greek
they were pledges the rapists okay and
you want to know what his brothers did
when they found out about this I'm
guessing something bad mm-hmm yeah they
do not go up to her and apologize and
say you know he's a bad egg so and so
Greek fraternity entered Greek words
this not Baptist we do not represent
this know they they harassed her they
said do not ruin this kid's life for one
dumb mistake he was intoxicated he was
this he wasn't thinking sure he thought
you were cute okay that's what they did
and that's why it's the stomach I was a
part of a fraternity here I left because
two members were put on our version of
our internal Supreme Court they were
giving chance out their chance of the
chance
they were put they were in they were in
positions of power within the TCU
community to where they were subject to
incoming freshmen they were subject to
other girls and they they use that power
in ways where they ended up harassing
these girls sexually assaulting these
girls that's terrible within the
fraternity they were given chance after
chance at the chance until they just
became maybe inactive can I take this
did not they were not big enough they
were not a part of the fraternity enough
to be to where they would shed badness
okay that's why a lot can I ask a
question
okay okay because you went you kind of I
think we'd both analogy jumped from a
few topics there so I'd like to kind of
donor in a couple then hopefully we can
move forward so you mentioned that this
man raped her the school knew about it
the police knew about it he was simply
moved to another house to simply move to
another dorm then you said that the
Greek house knew about it and basically
was encouraging and they harassed her
right okay do you have any proof
I wanted to count and that's that's
probably one of the reasons why it
wasn't my turn there was no there was no
GoPros everywhere you know there was
that's that's how it happens that's how
we just said proof was really important
so anyhow you just you just gave this
whole example to paint a picture of
white male privilege on campus and this
rape culture any proof and proof I
believe her and okay and there was you
know she lost her virginity there was
there is their stains you know there's
blood
I'm sure if you wanted to call FBI made
it make a big deal to have her name and
face painting everywhere
I'm sure okay proof okay so weird my
point we'd have to we have to find some
common ground and agreein some premises
here so no proof there that you would be
able to present that anyone has
presented you may be going but and of
assuming that she wasn't raped and I'll
take it under advisement but I do have
proof proof that there is not a rape
culture on campus you have proof there's
no yeah the statistic is not a one in
five rape corner the FBI it's one and
over eighteen hundred there's not a rape
culture on campus in the United States
these rapes do not occur without
consequence when there's proof presented
the constant
is not men getting away with rape I'm
surely not convinced of that I'm not
convinced by your account it sounds like
a harrowing account I feel horrible
that's at it occur so you think you
think I'm feel good about that I don't
think my point is well then listen you
can ascribe motive all you want but I do
that Virgil to get some laughs from some
people to put other people down someone
the only person who's insulting anyone
all day here all day is you you came in
addressing I know cuz I'm pissed I get
it serious I guess a coach and you have
a proof of that you say you don't I do
have proof and there is no rain or if
you're a girl you don't got to go out
you don't to put out that here I was
raped you don't want to do that you
don't want to be raped if you're a girl
obviously we were talking about the
statistics no but you said you don't
want it you don't want to go run in 5%
yeah there was no rape culture in the
United States campus I don't I don't I
don't I don't agree and the statistics
don't reflect that so if you had proof
the statistics of according the FBI
incorrect I would love for you to come
and sit down when you have the
microphone and I would love to talk
about that with you now you see this is
why this is not me being rude same thing
I gave up Chantal Chantal Chantal Chanel
sorry sorry sorry Chanel I apologize see
she's not gonna give me guff for she
sees it was an easy mistake I wanted her
to have her opportunity to speak I don't
necessarily agree with her
but I would say was very respectful you
were cussing yelling coming in a little
a little bit emotional and I want you to
have your opportunity to speak as well
and so it's disrespectful for her to
yell out we're having a conversation I
disagree this is not about Samantha it's
not about being like we're not in the
parliamentary system if they're not
allowed to interrupt it like that this
is important you're actually allowed to
interrupt in a parliamentary system
you're talking to someone who comes from
Canada I have a parliamentary shut up
with that much appreciate it man thank
you there you go thank you
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright